hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the 1959 just kidding 2018 candidates
tournament with a game from Alexander
Greece's Wesley so now both Greece Chuck
and Wesley lost their yesterday's game
was the lost of Fabiano Caruana and
Greece applause to Vladimir Kramnik so
both of them are definitely to gain at
least half a point if not a full point
so let's see this game
Grichuk opens it with E for we have E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 so the Royal Lopez we have a six more
fees defense Bishop to a 492 f6 and
castles Bishop to e7 d3 b5 Bishop to b3
and now d6 c3 Wesley castles and here we
have h3 and Wesley goes for Bishop to b7
another idea is to go tonight to a5 and
after white retreats with the bush of
then push c5 and then and then you'll
see what to do would would the light
square bishop but - Wesley goes for the
immediate Bishop to be 7 so Knight B to
d2
we have rook to e8 and now Knight to g5
and there's really no good way to defend
this f7 point so Wesley simply has to
retreat rook to f8 which he does if he
tried something like d5 to try and
defend f7 actively ad this simply
doesn't work with the idea that if he
captures Knight to a5 first you maybe
want to grab the bishop first and then
grab the phone back
but it doesn't work due to d6 and now
your bishop on e7 is attacked the f7
point is attacked and after all of the
exchanges Knight captures Queen captures
Bishop captures you simply lose upon
here even Bishop to b5 attacking whites
Queen simply captures captures captures
captures and after any move white will
be up upon and with a better position
so after this Knight to g5 Wesley
doesn't really have a choice here rock
back to f8 rook to e1 we have d5 he
captures Knight captures and Knight d2
f3 now Queen to d7 and now d 4e captures
on d4c captures on d4 and h6 Knight back
to e4
and now rook F to e8 Bishop to d2 Knight
to f6 and now rook to c1 Knight captures
only four rook captures on e4 and Bishop
to f6 and here grief shook the isn't
interested in exchanging Brooks as
Wesley a couple of his previous moves
were directed towards exchanging pieces
but a good issue goes for rook to g4
now there's the obvious threat of Bishop
captures I'm h6 and there really isn't a
good way a good way to deal with this in
the game Wesley played rook to a king to
h8 to simply get out of the pin but even
an active defense maybe rook a to the
8th simply allowing Bishop to h6
doesn't really work as a bishop captures
and after Knight captures and before
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
Queen to d2 a would would a very nice
tactic now after rook to e4 White has
this option of going rogue captures on
g7 Bishop captures and Queen to g5
simply threatening checkmate only way to
defend is Queen to d4 but now simply
Bishop captures and black cannot capture
back if he captures back of course Queen
captures rook wins the game for white
with the idea that you can't really move
the King to see two pins the rook and if
you defend what Queen to a fate then
Queen g5 check Queen blocks and now
Bishop captures on f7 again you can't
capture with the Queen you can't capture
with the King because of rook captures
on c7 and if after King moves simply
Queen check Queen h7 and now Queen
captures captures and row captors on c7
white is up three points it's completely
winning position so after this rook to
g4 Wesley decided to go rook to h8 but
now rook the c5 by Greece shocked rook a
to d8 and now comes the the move always
probably missed but you know it's just
things happen
Queen to c1 and now you see the the
terrible threat of Bishop capturing on
h6 now and also this Knight really can't
move because now the Queen and rook are
both attacking the c7 point so if you
combine both of this
I mean of course you can't capture and
before with the bishop or something like
that Bishop captures an h6 is simply
winning captures captures this is
checkmate and even if you don't capture
if you put g6 Bishop to f8 again winning
Queen to h6 is coming if you capture it
again Queen to h6 King moves Queen
captors and g6 the f7 pawn is pinned due
to the Bushman on b3 life has to move
and again it's checkmate
so after this Queen to c1 Wesley tried
one last idea it's the only move
basically he has he tried Knight
captures on d4 but now comes Knight
captures on d4 rook to e4 as you don't
really have the option of capture of
recapturing so rook to e4 and now rock
characters on c7 Queen captures on d4
now Bishop to e3 first getting rid of
the Queen and now you see the Queen
doesn't really have a good place to
defend the bishop on b7 so first was
they tried rook captures on g4 and now
with the idea that if Greece shook
captures the Queen then maybe he would
have some chances with rook captures and
g2 but even this wouldn't work for black
but the district isn't interested he
simply captures the rook on g4 and now
the Queen doesn't have a good square to
defend the bishop on b7 Wesley tried
Queen to e4 but now simply f3 and now
the Queen definitely has to move out of
the protection of the bishop winter
before was played preparing one last
trick after after Grisha captures the
bishop so rook captures and now Bishop
captures some b2 trying to give up the
dark square bishop as well as now if
Queen captures then Queen to e1 check
this will be a perpetual as King has to
move h2g 1:21 check King h2 Queen to h4
check but of course Richard isn't
interested in this he plays Queen to f1
and now is simply a piece up with
Wesleyan only having one pawn as a
compensation but ok he tried a couple of
more moves
f6 Queen to f2 now Bishop to e5
f4 better moves g5 Queen to e4 and here
Queen to f3 offering an exchange of
Queens and protecting the row can be
seven but even the even the G captures
on h6 was also winning but there's no
need to go into this as you wrap a piece
you don't need any more complications
simply Queen to f3 west of course
avoided that would check Queen F to
Queen back to before Queen back to f3 as
they are reaching move forty so you want
to reach that time control although okay
this is move thirty-six Queen b1 check
now King f2 Bishop before Queen to e2
Queen to b4 and now Queen to f3 and
Queen back to b1 and King to g3 this is
move forty now for Gray shook and now he
has all the time in the world so now he
will make some moves that will allow him
to finish the game f character son g4
was this fortieth move King to h2 we
have Queen to a5 rock to f7 simply
attacking the Queen Queen moves and now
we have F captures on g5 Bishop to d6
check King to H 3 and after this
kingfish three move Wesley so resigned
to the game as his still piece down and
that there are no more tricks in the
position after H captures on g5 simply
King to g4 and the king is actually very
safe on g4 black doesn't have a check
that that could even start a trick of
some sort and the White has plenty of
ways to win this either Queen to h3 this
will force an exchange of Queens as the
black King can never go to g8 this
Bishop on b3 will produce a lot of
discoveries or if if he wants he can
even maybe checkmate the black king with
Bishop b5 Bishop to c4 but iam after
this after this King to H to remove
Wesley still resigned the game and this
around to match up goes to go to
Alexander Bishop
so yeah that's a pretty bad start for
Wesley so starting in the candidates
with zero out of two but it's a long
tournament so I mean a couple of wins
and he's definitely back in the game and
I mean it wasn't so long ago since
Wesley had that unbeaten streak
I believe it's 59 or maybe 60 on games
that he went undefeated until he lost
that
first one to shock your mummy dro but
yeah lately it's it's just not not
Wesley's day like whenever he plays or I
don't know it just seems that way but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I did already asked this
question and a couple of my social media
networks who do you have your for your
pick on on winning the candidates and
aside from that who do you think will
win who produce the most interesting
match against Magnus Carlsen as you know
I kind of thought Kerrigan has a pretty
good chance of winning the candidates
but I I definitely don't want to watch
another course on vs. car I can match so
yeah and I don't know how many of you
are on Twitter but there's a very
interesting discussion going on on
Twitter it's basically a flame war
between Magnus cos and an onigiri but
it's very interesting a lot of people
are following it so and maybe you want
to check it out
so yeah that's it I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I thank y'all for watching
and I will see you soon